one notification trying to do everything
or ten notifications trying to take over
the whole notification shade how about
the best of both worlds with bundle
notifications by bundling notifications
into a group users will be able to act
on the entire group at once or expand
the group to see and act on the
individual notifications in the group
now I've talked about building a great
notification with notification compat so
let's assume you've already built great
individual notifications if users aren't
getting any benefit such as more
information or actions out of expanding
individual notifications you should work
on that first but once you have awesome
individual notifications bundling
similar notifications together is done
by calling set group for each
notification by default notifications
will be ordered by when they're posted
but you can override it with sort key
and the system will sort by that value
instead there's one other part the
bundle notifications though a summary
notification on marshmallow and lower
phones and tablets that don't directly
support bundled notifications only this
summary notification will be displayed
so make sure it's also a great
notification the inbox style is a great
candidate for these summary
notifications to give users a quick
overview of all the notifications they
have just make sure to call set group
with that same key and then call set
group summary true to denote that
notification as your summary
notification note you'll still want to
build a summary notification on devices
that support bundled notifications as
that's used indirectly by the system to
extract information for the header when
the group is collapsed now if you're
thinking to yourself hug ads set group
and set groups summary it sounds like a
lot of work there's two additional
reasons you should really bundle your
notifications for one there's a lot of
users out there already
with devices that support bundled
notifications every Android wear user
that's right by you
this API you're gonna making a great
experience for every one of those users
as well even if they're still using a
KitKat device secondly API 24 and higher
devices are going to bundle your
notifications for you if you post four
or more without any grouping and you
probably have a better idea what bundles
and summary notification makes sense for
your own app so if you're posting
multiple notifications use bundle
notifications to help you build better
apps